je voudrais moi aussi une félicité du
succès de cette primaire je l'avais
voulu je pensais en effet qu'il ne
fallait pas que le futur candidat de la
droite et du centre soit choisie d'une
manière verrouillé dans un parti
politique qu'il fallait que les français
soient largement associés le succès
était au delà de mes espérances avec
plus de 4 millions de français qui sont
déplacées je voudrais remercier en
particulier ceux qui m'ont placé en tête
de ce premier tour
ce deuxième tour c'est pas un combat
c'est la présentation des projets de
deux hommes qui appartiennent à la même
famille politique et qui je le pense on
la même éthique de l'action publique
c'est vrai que mon projet est plus
radical peut-être plus difficile c'est
le projet que j'ai bâtie avec les
français en parlant avec eux et en
comprenant leur colère leur exaspération
c'est aussi un projet qui rompt avec une
forme de pensée unique que j'ai vu se
déchaîner depuis quatre jours d'une
manière qui aurait pu prêter à sourire
si on ne parlait pas en fait de la
souffrance des français
la vérité c'est que les français sont
condamnés à une triple peine des impôts
toujours plus élevés qui grèvent leur
pouvoir d'achat
une dette abyssale qui hypothèque
l'avenir de leurs enfants et un chômage
qui provoque le déclassement d'un plus
grand nombre chaque année de nos
concitoyens mais ce débat ne doit pas
être celui de la division
parce que quel que soit le choix de
dimanche c'est ensemble que nous allons
mettre en oeuvre le projet que les
français vont choisir